The best way to immerse yourself in Chinese culture is by sampling its street food,...
...Chinese roadside hotpot or huoguo.
Bamboo skewers are neatly threaded with a supermarket's worth of vegetables and meats.
You can choose from tofu, lamb, chicken, pork, mushrooms, cabbage, kale and sausage on a stick.
Basically, you just point to whichever skewers you'd like,...
...and the vendor dips them in boiling oil for a few minutes before serving it to you.
Jiaozi or steamed dumplings.
This meat-packed Chinese treat is commonly served in sit-down restaurants,...
...but you can also find it being served in roadside stalls.
Shou zhua bing, which literally translates to hand-grabbed pancake.
This variation of the fried scallion pancake originated in Taiwan,...
...but is sold just about everywhere in Mainland China.